hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast the hurricane microbiome
projects environmental exposures and
population health presented by Joseph
Petrosino professor and interim chairman
Baylor College of Medicine
I am Alexis Krause of lab birds and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab Bert's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of online virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know they are
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Conte racino I
will now turn the presentation over to
him thank you to elaborate so give me
the opportunity to talk to you all about
a new project we have going on in our
laboratory very unique for microbiome
studies as far as I'm concerned and
hopefully one that you'll find both
educational and interesting at the same
time and so let's start off with an
overview for our for our talk for the
next 45 minutes or so I'm gonna touch on
some learning objectives that I saluted
and identified for for this talk I'll
describe a little bit background of how
we approach translational microbiome
research here at Baylor College of
Medicine a little bit of detail about
Hurricane Harvey that struck just about
a little over a year ago exposures and
health concerns that came from Hurricane
Harvey and how
investigators here in a Oregon State
University have partnered to study the
impact of the microbiome as it
correlates to environmental exposures
and health outcomes that have arisen
since the storm talk a little bit about
some preliminary results we found a
little bit descriptive but just to kind
of give you an idea of what we're
looking at and the future plans for this
study so starting off with our learning
objectives our group as I'll talk about
in moments has been involved in a number
of human microbiome originating stories
as well as others in the environment and
animal health as well starting before
the human microbiome project and all the
way till today okay is each microbiome
study has its a unique in interesting
perspectives and challenges in terms of
how to design and implement them and
this is no different on so in this case
we'd like to identify some thoughts
about how to deploy a microbial study
during a time of crisis in affected
community you can imagine how different
people are engaged in various aspects of
cleanup and pulling their lives together
and at the same time you're having to
engage this community and trying to help
identify potential biomarkers and
environmental exposures that may lead to
better responses in the future for
unfortunate events like this occur again
so we want to identify the research
questions that we that were following
such disasters hurricane Harvey are we
leverage the resources for rapid
deployment and acquisition of data from
these types of communities how does one
to study design a study to access both
short and long term health effects from
these exposures and then what
fundamental information should be
collected when sampling the human
microbiome stems from other studies as
well but applies specifically to this
hurricane study as well so before moving
forward I wanted to take a moment to
describe what we mean by translational
microbiome research and how we approach
it here at Baylor College of Medicine as
many of you probably have observed in
the literature there are a number of
studies that have that have described
the microbes
their taxonomy goes into the drawer
for communities that are associated with
health or disease or treatments and
control groups in a particular disease
model this is often interesting and has
led to a lot of different hypotheses
about how these microbes may be
associated with health or disease but in
reality it takes some functional
experiments with bottle systems builder
dissect how the host micro relationship
is occurring in this in a specific
disease what biomarkers and therapeutic
targets can be pulled out for new
diagnostics of therapeutics and how they
could be implemented to better improve
human or animal or environmental health
and so this slide captures this sort of
high-level we compare approach products
by comparing the microbiota and
healthier ill individuals identifying
communities or consortium strains in
these organisms perhaps even one in
these communities maybe even one strain
or even a metabolite that's produced by
a microbe and how these identify or
associated with health and disease take
this back to the laboratory in a model
system and be able to test hypotheses to
identify potential targets for
therapeutic development from these can
lead to all sorts of implementations to
improve human health including the
stratification of clinical trial
patients to better again address
treatments for certain diseases in 2011
following interaction with the human
microbiome project phase one we started
a translational microbiome research
center called the center for medicine
microbiome research where we implemented
this translational model for studying
microbiome and a variety of diseases so
this real diagram starts at the top at
12 o'clock with our sort of our inroads
to pretty much any microbiome project
that is a whole mix based exploration
comparing microbes and healthy versus
the ill individuals and dissecting these
relationships in animal or other
cellular model systems identifying
therapeutic targets that could be
developed for eventual translation from
the bench back to the bedside
also very important in this is policy
and outreach whether we educate our
general public as well as politicians
and regulatory agencies to the benefits
of bio therapeutic treatment of disease
with microorganisms
and of course training the next
generation of Sciences our educational
systems we also have a commercialization
arm where we've launched multiple
companies now but the first which is the
origin which does these or helps with
these services types of services with
pharmaceutical i'll check companies the
way that we look at the microbiome is a
element a component is a precision
medicine paradigm that is as you're
walking through a doctor's office it's
becoming more and more clear that just
the traditional clinical data that you
provide is in the clinical data they
were generated through blood samples
this is not enough to be able to discern
the various versions of diseases that
people get from place to place from time
to time and now we can implement human
genomic data and metabolomic did their
proteomic data now microbiome data and
taken into context also the environment
that you live in what part of the world
that you live in what type of diet you
consume what other exposures there are
to be able to better inform treatments
that may be better for your your
condition your part of the world at that
given time as opposed to others in other
parts of the world versus a one
treatment for all disease paradigm that
and we've largely lived under for the
last sense of dining medicine and so the
microbiome can definitely have an
endpoint in crank on precision medicine
not just as it's related to ourselves
but because it's also a component that
responds to the environment that were
around so it's the microbiome is
somewhat of a handshake between the
environment that we're in and our human
genetic backbone is at work and
microbiome based applications are our
omics based applications a lot of what
we do starting out that starts off with
a metagenomic with genomic process
that's outlined here and so at the top
of the screen I showed that we are able
to collect and design experiments for
any type of environment or human
condition collect samples that are that
are applicable for that condition and by
now we've seen pretty much everything
extract DNA and RNA is applicable with a
particular project sequence that in a
variety of sequence
platforms again as applicable for
project we also work with the human
genome sequencing Center at Baylor
College of Medicine which is one of the
three large-scale NHGRI funded
sequencing centers the United States it
also offers a large capacity a large
variety of sequencing opportunities and
platforms for us to use and then
depending on the questions we want to
ask and apply a variety of ion formatic
outputs to the data set to be able to
ask what is it microbial community look
like in healthy versus ill individuals
whether the genes are contained in those
organisms so now I'm not just a taxonomy
but also the genetic functions that are
encoded by these organisms we can
assemble entire genomes from single
organism so we can identify specific
features of a strain of interest
belonging to a specific disease or
protected cohort we can also do RNA
sequencing so not only are we getting at
the genes that are present in a given
sample which ones are turned on at a
particular disease State or in
particular condition on pointing more
directly at a potential therapeutic or
diagnostic target I come from a
virologist part Minh and if I didn't
talk about viruses they Lynch me so as
we also been working hard at developing
better technologies to sequence and
analyze and detect viruses from these
types of samples as well we've built
these platforms to be able to do
metagenomics at a large scale because we
think about disease as I alluded to the
precision medicine slide earlier we want
to think about it from a global
perspective we don't want to look at
disease just in Houston Texas or in one
region of the world we want to be able
to study disease such as type 1 diabetes
by studying cohorts from all over the
world so that we identify both the
common exposures the common genetic
risks the common microbial signatures
associated with disease matter where
you're from and also the regional
factors that may be different from place
to place you kind of time so those may
be impacted by diet or the raising of
ethnic background of a particular part
of the world access to health care the
environment there are a variety of
things that implement that are that
impact local implica currencies of
disease that will be reflected in the
microbiome of those those individuals as
well so being able to do this will take
led us to
both targets that are universal to given
disease and those that are regional as
well so again better informed
personalized medicine approach to
disease sustained disease when I touched
just for a second and if I mentioned
that we when you get an association with
health and disease you don't stop there
you need to take back to the laboratory
and dissect those microbial
relationships we have several faculty at
Baylor and those are technologies that
some of the implemented elsewhere being
able to study bacteria in many bio
reactors so think about the big team of
stats that people grow large numbers of
organisms and large volumes of organisms
then Rob written here Baylor has been
working with many bio reactors 15 mill
versions of those cultures that you can
grow in parallel up to the 96 or more at
a time to be able to Iturbe uniquely and
see the effect of a certain drug or
certain microbe and how it impacts got
community overtime a condition that
mimics the guts as well buck samuel
works as what c elegans is as a model
for studying metabolism and other their
host features that actually are readily
reproducible or associated in C elegans
in the worm model and Mary Estes is a
Rolla gist National Academy member and
our apartment androids grown from stem
cells collected from biopsies of adult
individuals able to regrow them in the
laboratory to differentiate them to
create mini guts and be able to
introduce microbes and viruses to those
mini guts to look at these cell to cell
associations that are occurring not only
within the longitudinal digestive tract
of a single individual but across
multiple individuals giving you a an
insight on how unique some of these
interactions really are in Aldens - his
letter r germ-free mouse facility that's
been going on now for about five years
it's one of the largest term free
facilities and the lesson believed at
the moment we have over 100 Isolators
looking at both mice and rats is my us
systems that study those micro
relationships I mentioned that we've
seen a lot of different diseases here's
just a small snapshot of some of them
and
and the people that we worked with over
the over the last seven years
estimate over 300 probably 350 projects
now with over 200 collaborators from
around the world touching on any disease
and that you could probably imagine and
some bets you've made out of thought up
to this point Tom been a very
interesting when an ADHD science type of
approach to engage in the microbiome
it's really you had something at you're
interested in one day that's great but
something else the next day comes up and
makes the call it's even more exciting
but it's been amazing to see how some of
the associations with the cities that
we've been able to dissect even further
over the years so one project I want to
talk about today of course is with
respect to Hurricane Harvey so for those
who aren't familiar hurricane Harvey
struck August 24th actually August 25th
as a category category 4 hurricane
Houston in the surrounding area Houston
sees its fair share of hurricanes I've
been here for about 26 years almost and
pretty much every other year there seems
to be a hurricane of some size that
that's a struggle tropical storm that
that rolls through during the summer but
this one was it was unique in the fact
that it came over and it stalled over
Houston for several days creating
unprecedented flooding in the area
dropped over 50 inches of rain and
affected over 41 counties in Texas
anyone doesn't know all of them were
designated as federal disaster areas a
quarter million homes that were damaged
100,000 in county that houses Houston as
you can imagine with that kind of deluge
there's all sorts of potential hazards
and issues that come from a region that
actually is already actually humid and
hot so there's and some of these
headlines and articles sort of capture
some of that but you think about first
of all the evacuation process then
coming back to your home that's been
inundated with water walls have to be
torn out of course that generates dust
and that releases molds that have been
growing both before and then after the
storm that set
mosquitoes love of course this type of
environment so there's all sorts of bad
nasty things that can happen which is
why this is not really a great tourism
presentation for the city of Houston
it's a great place to live otherwise as
many of you saw in the news I think
there was an unprecedented the the
amount of community act engagement in
terms of people rescuing one another
people pulling out boats and getting
jumping into the water and having no
regard for what may be in there to
rescue and pull people out it was
actually a pretty amazing sight to
experience and of course the addition of
health concerns that I didn't mention
before included bobbing the drinking
water systems flood water contamination
the fact that this pretty much walking
in a potential toxic soup for those
Houston's also a has a huge
petrochemical footprints as well and
there's a number of chemical and
explosive hazards that result from the
from breaching the safety systems of
these various plants most again or under
control and have measures in place to
deal with this but that doesn't mean
that it's a hundred percent foolproof
of course we have mentioned mosquitoes
and cancerous diseases that come from
mosquitoes exposure and of course the
stress that it brings on specific
individuals or the affected individuals
there's people still today that work in
our laboratory and associated with our
laboratory that you start talking about
this project actually for a certain
period of time they actually get
emotionally affected and you can see it
still has a dramatic impact on what some
people had to go through because of
something because of what they went
through NIH has a mechanism to to better
understand and better improve our
Disaster Response program the di2
mechanism is a disaster research
response program as a framework to look
at the medical and public health aspects
of disasters and health emergencies it's
managed primarily through an IP address
and library Madison supports a website
to help engage
these types of research programs and so
investigators who have Baylor led by a
shell Walker who directs our Center for
precision Environmental Health gathered
a team of individuals and some of whom
are shown here to build a personal write
grants to support this research and then
also to coordinate the activities so
that we can hit the ground running and
get some of the baseline measurements
that are needed to make the research
most effective and so Melissa Bonnie
when he Hamilton from a new T school
University Texas Houston Health Science
Center contributed as well as Elaine
Szymanski and then an Oregon State Kim
Anderson actually provided a very unique
perspective to this project that I'll
talk about in a minute conceptual model
is pretty straightforward it's been
discussed in the literature most
recently in 2014 the idea that after
disaster there's a rapid needs
assessment of health surveillance
program that's that is engaged to look
at the recovery from post to at during
the post disaster response it's
following this post exact disaster
response ordering it where there's track
there's epidemiologic studies that can
be launched to better understand and
better prepare for the future and it's
in this latter epidemiologic stage where
the VI team are two mechanism is most
applicable and that's that's the time
it's a period of time that we were most
interested in implementing this program
that I'm about to describe so we sent me
set as a team to identify you know how
can we put together a group of
individuals with the resources we have
to better inform a response for both
public health and population health and
to protect those who are most vulnerable
in our community and so we wanted to
start off with the goal of evaluating
the chemical environmental exposures and
the health conditions that came up that
arose after Harvey and to assess the
biomarkers associated
his exposures that will inform best
practice for future and so Houston has a
number of Superfund sites and so for
those who aren't familiar the US has
identified sites there that are been
cleaned up of toxic and chemical waste
and there's special measures that are on
earth that are underway in each of these
Superfund sites Houston has 15 of them
in surrounding areas again it's another
tourism in Houston that could
potentially pose a threat to human
health mold exposures are also concern
again it's a humid and especially after
the hurricane a very humid environment
very hot power is out and so a lot of
the pathogens and vectors to these
diseases can can can over grow and
affect human human health as well as
impact the water supply which of course
will then just turn around infect human
health as well the the illnesses can be
associated also with the type of
chemicals the amount the duration the
routine status of the individual
inhalation is always a an important
route of exposure for indoor
environments and therefore we're very
interested in seeing if we could take
samples that would help us evaluate the
impact and the respiratory tract of some
of these exposures all this is being
taken into consideration we wanted to
recruit individuals who have been
affected so there's a number as bad as
the storm was there was definitely areas
of Houston as I'll show you in a moment
there were areas that were much more
affected than others so we want to make
sure we were engaging those communities
and so we also want to engage children
as well so those who were five and older
were asked to participate in the study
if their parents consented those who
were either living in a flooded home or
cleaned up as a result result of Harvey
on the other side of the equation we had
limited resources and therefore we
limited limited our recruitment to one
adult one child per household
it was the response and the engagement
has been great so far and so it's we
actually have to be be mindful of how
many people take in from one small from
one house south and so one of the
stupider resources appropriately so we
had to arms to iron in terms of
recruitment in terms of recruitment
groups one arm about people who no
longer exposed but were sort of
initially had been exposed to
floodwaters or flood damage we started
the Roma crosses about 30 days out so
these are people that were probably
helping others but probably didn't have
home damage themselves we have them
complete a Health Questionnaire and
provide samples for microbiome studies
and fecal samples oral saliva samples
and a nasal swab the second arm were
those who were more long-term exposure
and these are people who had the same
type of information samples collected
but also had a were given a silicone
wristband from the Anderson Group at
Oregon State so I mentioned that she had
a really interesting contribution she's
developed a wristband that can passively
sample over 1,500 organic compounds that
that band is exposed to so as you were
wearing it on the wrist that wristband
will take in the chemicals that your
identifier you're exposed to as well as
how your body reacts to them in terms of
what's secreted from their skin so it's
looking at both the exposure as well as
some of the response that exposure at
least as a at least as it's passed
through the skin very interesting and
some a lot of data that could be
correlated now with our microbiome data
and our questionnaire data a home sample
is also collected from those that were
under current and constant exposure we
developed a questionnaire to capture
general information from each study
participants so social demographic data
exposure data how much you participated
in our remediation activities in current
health health impact environmental
health so information about the
environment that you're currently living
in and some diet information so we had a
baseline to look at with your microbiome
data
the exposure log eggs just an example of
some of the information was collected in
terms of what you were living in butcher
cleaning and and what the remediation
process was for your area and the
wristbands that were passed out were
then of one for a week and then brought
back to the collection site that
following weekend the wristbands
themselves is a little bit more
information about about them and some
the information that were provided and
some of Kim's dr. Anderson's personnel
shown on the right-hand side these bands
can collect information about both
person personal care products various
chlorinated chemicals pesticides by
cyclical aromatics and it can be worn
while you were doing all sorts of things
it's just one throughout the week so
you're able to collect all the exposures
that you you potentially were associated
with for that period of time from a
microbiome perspective we had years of
experience and working with groups that
have found ways to help collect
microbiome samples that would keep them
stable during transit especially when
there was no refrigerated conditions at
the time that so we're using fecal
collection kits oral nasal swabs a
Slovak passive collection in a home swab
where a lot of people could sample
specific areas of their homes the idea
was to launch a study within 30 days of
Hurricane Harvey and then begin to
collect information about first of all
collect information from the individuals
involved and then to assess how that
original collection went to inform a
secondary time point and 12 months later
where we can collect more more samples
from the same into 150 individuals that
were sampled in September of 2017 so
we're coming up on that right now and
another 150 individuals were going and a
cross-sectional measure too to get again
more information about what people were
exposed to and how it impacted the
microbiome as well so of 150 people
sample twice and then another hundred
fifty Cent people sampled a year
you're out one time and then all the
data are going to be integrated to look
at potential associations with exposures
to potentially identify ways in which
the responses to these types of events
could perhaps be improved the
participating communities are shown here
so the overall this is a map of Harris
County Houston actually it's not even
all of Houston but it's mostly Houston
or most of Houston so when I refer to a
couple of these communities repeatedly
and so they kind of give you that at the
left the highlighted community that's
labeled number one was an area called
addicts in West Houston talk about some
of the demographics in a second on the
right side community in side of the map
is this Bay town we're a lot of our
petrochemical plant suits East Houston
is number two sort of in the middle and
we also sampled people that were
affected who belong to the Baylor
College of Medicine community there's
actually a number of Devon I'll talk
about well I have a map that shows
specifically where people were living at
this time or at the time of sample the
they're also indicated in red star zones
slide the active Superfund sites so
known chemical or other toxic waste
[Music]
repositories they're under federal
management for cleanup that potentially
could have been compromised during the
storm if we look at the populations
themselves again attics the attics area
is sort of middle-income a town was a
site that was close to two Superfund
sites East Houston is a lower-income
area of the community and mostly of
minority population and then Baylor
employees again was the fourth category
if we look at the where these people
were located and there were centers at
each sites where people came in and were
sampled but of course people could come
in from all over to have the most of
people at the sites we chose for sample
information collection were more
centralized in the areas I'm
but some of these people were living
further away
and so I want to make sure we collected
that information as well as we began to
make our association conclude draw our
conclusions from our associations and so
the individuals has they're broken down
by the recruitment centers and where
they actually lived are shown here
demographics of these areas are area
cated here I'm not sure if this we
really need to spend a lot of time on
this but again you can see the median
income of the household income at the
bottom over all Harris County which is
sort of representative Baylor College of
Medicine
Madison group you see the breakdown of
male-female they're all normal splits as
you imagine but just to give you an idea
again of all the meta data that we're
collecting and associated associated
with the exposures and the health risks
that will come out at the end of this
study it's important to underscore that
so we began the first collection site
was actually at Baylor this is sort of
way to get your feet under you in terms
of sampling a lot of individuals you get
a feel for how this is impacting people
that are still actively going through
their cleanup and remediate remediation
from the storm a questionnaire was sent
out through all employees or 8,000
people and 400 responded within a week
and and some of them were among those
who were then sampled so we're on top of
the actual sampling we're collecting a
lot of other sort of a survey data that
can be layered on top of these analyses
in this program as well 60% of the
responders had forms are uninhabitable
uninhabitable or destroyed and 38
percent were actually trying to work
their way through living while their
home was still partially flooded I'm a
touch-based
really quickly on a few of these other
sites attics again we located a church
in the community that was a hub for
[ __ ] guts activities and these are
these are people that come out and
volunteer to help people other people
who are affected clean out our homes cut
out the drywall and get them in a place
where they can start the rebuilding
process and so we had to recruitment
sessions the ones that were week later
were mainly to collect
apples that were wristbands and fecal
samples after they were collected and
brought back similar situation in
Baytown hurting over the church that was
many parishioners homes were affected by
the flood waters and had to collection
centers sessions a week apart East
Houston was a actually a delivery
Recovery Center that was set up to serve
the community residents again collected
one weekend schedule samples one weekend
where spans the next weekend just to
give you an idea of how many people
enrolled and how many belong to the arm
one versus arm two who got the
wristbands I can see the live people
were still living in homes that were
damaged the arm two group overall
collected two hundred eight participants
so over collect initially to to ensure
that when we go back out in the
community now that we can get at least
150 people for two time points
wristbands came back at a 90% rate so
that was that was exciting - compliance
is always an important feature when
you're building a cohort of any kind
microbiome samples over 658 652
microbiome samples are collected from
the first round you can see how they
were broken down from basil Sylar fecal
environmental I'm going to talk a little
bit now in the last Oh nine or ten
minutes if I have left about some of the
information was collected from the
microbiome samples and just 2/9 those
believe a broad audience I'm going to
talk about alpha diversity and that is
look at the microbiome data we look at
how many different taxa are present in a
particular in a particular community or
a particular sample type so this is
basically the number of different
species or genera that are found in a
particular organic community and then
their evenness how well are they this
distributed are they relatively the same
numbers of everything that's there or
there are large disparities in the
abundance of particular taxol in the
community and that's reflected in a
couple measures I'll talk about in a
moment we'll talk a little microbial
taxonomy what's there when
the names of the organisms that are
there and then comparison between
samples community makeup and so
basically looking at the different
organisms and the relative abundances
and a particular component at with all
other samples it's Niihau related the
samples are how much they resemble one
another from sample to sample
so the first measure we took this is now
looking at bacterial 16s data which
limits us pretty much to option
observationally taxonomic units that's
akin to species but gives us sort of a
97% identity between the 16s sequences
that were looked at this is before
sequencing and comparing them across the
different sample types we identified and
can serve ODU again operational
taxonomic immunity
difference differences between samples
you can see that there are a lot of
difference about 200 different Oh to use
an environmental sample versus fewer and
nasal slime and stool samples we look at
the diversity index again those are
environmental samples turned out to be
very diverse as you'd imagine compared
to those who are found in niches of the
body if you mentioned these data just
recently this first analysis again it's
a first-time point so this is from in
September 2007 17 and you know the
samples collected extracted sequence
primary analyses were we simply derived
and we're going through them one of the
first groups to see this see this data
so some of the stories have not been
borne out behind what we're talking
about here yet there is seem to be some
differences in the halfa diversity of
different numbers of organisms present
in or distribution and depending on
where you are located and so the
locations are indicated in a key on the
right because a respect to color they
correspond to letters on the bottom of
the slides as well so it is xB as
Baytown he is Baylor College of Medicine
it inches East Houston they'll be used
repeatedly throughout the talk
again what we did see is that samples
that came from Houston didn't seem to
have a slightly different slightly
higher diversity in nasal and saliva
compared to compared to the other
communities don't know what that means
we're just right now this is the script
of stage of the study as you'd imagine
this if we look at beta diversity now
how look how with each dot representing
the composition of each sample so the
organisms that are there and the
relative abundance if you're looking at
a weighted analysis versus unweighted
analysis which is just comparing the
organisms that are present at absence if
you're looking at this there are samples
are labeled by body type sample type and
so those are shown in the the keys
environmental nasal saliva oral sorry
environmental nasal saliva and stool and
as you imagine they the communities are
present each type of sample are unique
to that type of sample they cluster
together as you can see interestingly
the environmental and nasal communities
seem to be closer together at least when
you look at the unweighted analysis
that's just the presence and absence of
organisms suggesting that some of the
exposures that are coming from the
environment they'll have the first
impact of the most impact on the basal
communities that's normally the case and
so just reminds us the fact that if
there's things that are potentially
toxic in the environment or potentially
pathogenic in environment the first
confers body site that will see them
this is going to be the nasal cavity
these data start to compare the scent of
Beta diversities of the composition of
each sample by location it's hard to see
here and it's we're not rotating or
using animations at this point Abbott
there were some some features as you
rotate these three dimensional plots
that made it look like you can actually
see some clustering by area specifically
if you are looking at East Houston if
you look at the saliva data soft
the lower-right actually were able to
rotate this you can see that the the
East Houston is all more coming out of
the screen and in that case may have
some features that differentiate from
the others saliva samples MOCA meanings
it's an ongoing analysis not not readily
seen perhaps in the way that's depicted
here but there are some features that
suggest that there's some unique tax
either a president each community
similarly if you look at this now with a
weighted measure so that was unweighted
presence and absence of organisms this
is not looking at the relative abundance
of organisms similarly you're gonna
start to see if you rotate these around
there may be some associations by by
area but we have to look at the look at
this in more detail as I mentioned the
nasal and environmental samples seem to
have some overlap and so when we focus
focus that I'm those alone you can see
that in the unweighted presence and
absence weighted putting relative
abundance all those communities so that
there's some environmental and nasal
organisms are being shared the top 10
most abundant bacteria and the
environment are found in all
environments so if there's there are
differences it's not at the most
abundant organisms levels so these are
the top 10 bacterial genera that were
found in each each of the communities
and how they relate to one another from
town from area to area they're all found
in each area and then I'm looking at
these top 10 genera and how they are
present in other sample types and so we
do see that environmental organisms
these are their abundances are in blue
are actually found in nasal saliva and
even samples in some cases suggesting
that there are shared taxa with our
environment and samples they're
collected from them now again this is
going to be normally the case our
environment has a huge impact on the
microbes that are honest and in US but
the question will become as we move
further into this analysis as to how how
many of them are actually harmful for us
or are any of them powerful harmful to
us are they associated with health
are they associated with specific
exposures in the environment we also
start a look at fun fungi and so the i
TS - is a akin to the 16s marker gene
Robison RNA gene in humans sorry in
bacteria the IPS - is an internal
transcribed spacer region of the
ribosomal RNA in fungi and eukaryotes
and so resequenced this to be able to
start to discern what the fungal
communities look like in these samples
and so again initially looking at
environment and nasal swabs the saliva
and stored data are yet to come you can
see that there's a large again large
number of taxa that are found in the
applicants or those who use in the
environment samples and then nasal also
has a large number of fungal it appears
not quite as much as our metal samples
again great diversity found in the East
Houston samples and I'm not sure what
this necessarily means at the moment but
both in a nasal especially the nasal
swab there seems to be more fungal taxa
that are present in that community if
you look at the diversity beta diversity
of nasal environmental swabs you can see
that there is some overlap look looking
at each of the areas and that were
sampled there's some taxes for sure
overlap with the environmental samples
and of course as many others that do not
as we look at the taxes specifically
they'll dissect this even more again
another nasal environmental data
diversity of plots that are showing how
the nasal fungi seem to be if you look
it specifically at there right on the
fungi and the nasal swab seem to be
offset from the the East Houston seem to
be awesome from other areas of the city
taxonomically the next couple of slides
I'm going to kind of go through this
quickly so we have time for questions
but if you look at the environmental
samples at the top and the nasal samples
at the bottom the taxa they're color
coded on sale on the right you can see
that there are some taxes that are
shared
some of these tax would have been
associated with incidences of Allergy
and Asthma and so be interesting they're
seeing some of the health outcomes as
the associated with these environmental
basil samples forward again the as we
look at these particular data the top
ten fungal genera in the environment is
found in the nose and so all these were
found the environment how many of these
were found in nasal swabs
Kerrville Kerrville area is a highly
abundant is and any animal samples and
it's also detected in the nasal samples
and some more abundant in East Houston
so just an example of how we're tying
location environmental sample and nasal
samples together and we'll tie this back
to health outcome forward so the next
steps of all this and that was just
again very descriptive very high-level
taxonomic profiles of the organisms
present and what's next is to start to
tie these and it's descriptive data to
the demographics the health history is a
diet of individuals to the chemical
exposures and other exposure information
that we're collecting to be able to look
at what biomarkers what taxa are
associated potentially with these
exposures and health outcomes to better
inform what could be done in the
responses in forward we have a 12-month
sampling point that's beginning right
now actually in the within the next week
actually one sites are them we sampled
and we're moving to the other two
shortly and then the protocols that were
using today I have been informed by the
protocols and how they work last year so
again you refine your study method
without without changing the actual
samples they're being collected because
you don't want to reduce bias into so
how the data may look from one year to
the year prior but in terms of how best
to engage the community those changes
have been implemented to the sample time
we also want to also mention we all are
wanting to return data back to the
subjects so that they can understand at
a population level how they're how this
research will impact
how this research will impact them both
in terms of information about the
exposures that they're all living
through and how this potentially can be
turned into better better responses to
disaster moving forward
lots of ongoing and plan analyses moving
forward there's other other pieces of
information that we can bring in that
we're not part of the actual state of
design so information about the
Superfund sites petrochemical facilities
there's a urban Data Platform of air
quality and other compounds that can be
also brought in to look at these
exposures as a really super microbiome I
mentioned the word spend analysis
they're coming back as well as
additional information about the
microbiome and microbiome
from the data that are that are at hand
and so with that I know we kind of whiz
through some of the mission analysis but
of course happy to answer any questions
more forward those that may not even
come up today but later in the future
couldn't have done this without the help
of the laboratory as well as the Center
for precision precision environmental
health and Cheryl Walker's group Kim
Anderson making Oregon State University
can Elaine animale at the University of
Texas Health Science Center in Houston
thank you thank you dr. Patterson we
will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question jot down box
located on the far left to your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button our speaker
will follow up with your questions via
email so let's get started
our first question is we know that the
functions of the organisms found in a
microbiome sample are important are
their planned analysis to study the gene
content of these samples as well so yes
we have a number of again we have
already over 650 samples and have been
collected we wanted to get a initial
profile using 16s and I TS to sequence
data about what's in these samples but
as a question suggests the functions the
these organisms are actually doing is
what's most important in these types of
analyses and so in order to do that
we'll do the whole genome shotgun
sequencing on these samples look at the
gene content of all the of these
communities you'll associated those
genetic functions whatever the outcomes
that we've talked about the exposures
we've talked about the respond data so
look at what functions are selected in
these particular types of environments
and exposures now dr. Petrus tena are
there plans to look at viruses in these
samples that's a good question so the
viruses as I mentioned before is an
important component of the microbiome
initially it was maybe under studied or
under representative but now there's a
number of studies of launched in space
with the samples that we have in hand we
don't have virus analyses planned have
banked samples primary sample that's
left or we can go back with perhaps
additional resources and study the virus
is there any examples in integrate that
same analysis that we talk about now it
looks like we have time for one more
question
well samples be collected from
individuals who do or have become sick
to see if the etiologic agent was found
in the local environment also an
interesting question so as I mentioned
we we have some initial exposure
information so environmental organisms
that seem to be associated with
organisms found on the body sites that
we've studied but if people become sick
if an etiological agent was discovered
can we go back and see if that that
organism was found in the environment at
that particular location when the
subjects have been consented for
reconsent
to be seven consented in their IRB as
part of the consent process to be part
of the study they have been asked if
they would be like to be I we contacted
should such an event occur those that's
that indicated that they would we would
be able to go back and collect those
samples potentially make that kind of a
connection I'd like to once again thank
dr. Petrosino for his presentation
I would also like to thank lab birds for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing your
December of 2018 you will receive an
email from laberd's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with their colleagues who may have
missed today's event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye